we're incredibly excited about being
here working on the first ever
commercial shot entirely in IMAX IMAX is
all about delivering this amazing
entertainment experience and our focus
was to remind you why you love what we
do when people think about IMAX quite
often people are just thinking about the
big screen or the sound but what people
tend to forget is that IMAX is all about
just delivering an experience that is
based around this pure love and passion
for movies so we essentially just sat
down and wrote a poem which is really
about our love for film and we thought
the best possible way to bring that to
life would be to capture it with a
timeless camera
we wanted to remind people of all the
genres of films that make IMAX so
special whether it's a Chinese language
film or an action-adventure movie or the
superhero movies for which we're so
famous so originally the plan was just
to deliver the poem almost as a
voiceover but when we started to talk to
our director Ashe about how to really
bring it to life he had a bigger idea I
thought wouldn't it be great that you
took the main things that you see in
films and then the main character in
their scene sees that to the audience
and say I love films as well it's a hard
thing to do sometimes to break the
fourth wall but in a way it can actually
be really amazing in the sense of like
it makes us more intimate and it's part
of the audience and so when you're
watching it and you feel like you're a
part of the film as well China is a very
important market for the imax brand and
as such we wanted to make sure that we
shot
we didn't just shoot 11 Saints we shot
11 films and I hope that everybody
enjoys watching it as much as we enjoy
late yeah
the IMAX cameras are very much in high
demand so it's really exciting that we
were able to get two of the Alexa IMAX
cameras for our IMAX branchy this is a
format of which I've never seen the kind
of clarity and resolution before or in
any other medium and being able to shoot
so wide but have such detail it's been
truly fantastic learning experience
because of the nature of IMAX and being
a big screen was important to me that we
weren't handheld and throwing the camera
around will really smooth for that
that's an amazing thing about these
lenses and the camera they're helped us
do that one of the lines in the
manifesto is I sweat the details and in
many ways that single line is the
personification of what everybody here
at IMAX does we sweat every single
detail to deliver a most amazing movie
experience that you can possibly have